Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P. Today's caller asks a very
personal question about parenting. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hi, David. Are you the kind of father
that would spank your children and wife?
Speaker 1: No. No, I don't even. Do I really
need to say more? I mean, the the answer
is, is now let's just leave it there. We
have a fantastic bonus show for you today. The
World Cup has started in Qatar. I am genuinely.
Split 5050. On the one hand, I could not be more
disgusted at the lead up. So, I mean, listen,
corruption in the selection of
Qatar to even host a World Cup.
Use of what is essentially slave labor indentured
servitude to build the stadiums in Qatar.
Most recently, Qatar won't allow any kosher food
or public Jewish prayer. In and around the World
Cup. This is a horrible extremist authoritarian
regime. On the other hand, as an Argentinean.
I love the World Cup and I love watching the
Argentinean men's national team. I'm thinking
about getting up at 5 a.m. tomorrow to watch
the first game. And this is we're going to
talk about World Cup and what's going on in Qatar
on the bonus show. That's number one. Secondly,
CBS News went on hiatus from Twitter after
supposedly over security concerns and then
is now back to posting on Twitter what happened?
Is it weird? Is it a call for attention? What's
going on? We will discuss it. And thirdly, Nasser
is now saying that by the year 2030, this is only
eight years away at this point. By the year 2030,
astronauts will be living and working on the moon.
You know, we heard all these predictions about we
would be on Mars by 2024. We're not going to be,
etc., etc.. That don't seem plausible. They never
seemed plausible. Mars 2028. And seeming a little
difficult. But maybe. Working and living on the
moon by 2030 seems much more plausible. But will
it happen? And what would be the point? We're
going to talk about those stories and more on
today's bonus show. This is a shortened week,
just so everybody knows. We are here Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday. We will then be off the rest
of the week for the Thanksgiving federal holiday
in the United States. Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
Wednesday will sort of be like a Friday show and
we will have new content on the Paramount
Finance Channel. We will have new content
on Pacman Live. Everything else will sort of be
normal, but it will just be a shortened week for
the holiday and then we will be indeed back next
week. We're going to speak to you on the bonus
show. You can sign up at join Pacman dot com.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money. Yeah. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Alex Jones is the last person at
this point to be commenting on business advice,
given what's going on with his
hemorrhaging of money. But yes,
you sign up at join Pacman dot com, you can use
the coupon code 24 starts now and very soon,
maybe tomorrow, maybe Wednesday I will be able
to announce the release of our first white paper.
I think you're going to like this. Talk to
you on the bonus show or otherwise tomorrow.